a surfer in northern california survived
a bite from a great white shark last
weekend now these attacks are rare and
almost always involve an adult shark
carter evans went to a california beach
where juvenile great whites routinely
swim with surfers now researchers are
getting up close to find out why this is
happening
during what's proving to be a very busy
shark season off southern california
just beyond the surf camp students in
the shore break there's a fin out there
a site that's terrifying for most people
it's actually one of many most swimmers
never even see them but video from above
shows countless baby great white sharks
up to six years old and 10 feet long
swimming among families and surfers it's
becoming so familiar here something
unusual is happening to these kids and
their parents
uh
they're not afraid so you've seen sharks
out there when your son is out here yes
it sounds weird to say doesn't it yes i
almost don't want to think about it too
much
anna rudnicki says her perception of the
apex predator is changing i guess if my
kid's right there and i just saw a shark
go by then yeah it must be changing
surf camp owner chris keat has a plan
when a shark gets too close what happens
then we blow a whistle we have everyone
come inside the surf line we call it
code black so take a look here this is
the surf camp all the kids are out in
the water and that guy on the paddle
board there he is a shark spotter making
sure to keep these kids safe they have
basically come to accept the fact that
there are sharks here and they're
learning how to live with them
chris lowe runs the shark lab at cal
state long beach we met him and his team
just a few hundred yards offshore from
the surf camp i see it i see it there it
is during a week-long expedition tagging
and tracking a record number of juvenile
great whites we want to be able to
predict where these sharks will show up
and to better understand what's
attracting the sharks they have to catch
one it goes from zero to 100 very very
quickly researcher james anderson and
the team wrangle it along the boat it's
thrashing it's trying to get away and
then you've got to untangle it from the
net
get it onto its back so that it then
calms down and goes into a tonic
mobility state he takes blood and tissue
samples to help learn what the shark is
eating may be a clue to why the shark is
here then he performs surgery at sea and
the tag implanting a tracking device
that will last a decade
that's researcher emily spurgeon getting
hands-on with the 150-pound juvenile
shark
she's responsible for monitoring and
maintaining a network of underwater
hydrophones listening for tagged sharks
swimming by so we're tracking these
juvenile white sharks from mexico all
the way up to the central coast of
california this is all part of
aggregating the data so you can
eventually maybe predict when sharks
will be around that's the goal so if i
can figure out if this habitat is
perfect for them then maybe we can say
if another beach has similar conditions
then those sharks might be moving there
ultimately the team hopes to create a
shark report to go with the surf report
so southern california beachgoers know
when to expect company in the water
you saw jaws when you were a kid i did
yeah i had a lot of misconceptions uh
hello shark the children see
the animals and they no longer are
fearing them in the same way off the
coast of santa barbara i'm carter evans
for cbs mornings
i don't get it
you know why you don't get it well
you're a west coast guy but i was gonna
say it's different in california with
the sharks they say the sharks act
differently on the east coast there's
different feeding patterns and it's not
quite as safe okay we know there's
nothing funny about shark attacks but
they say it's usually adult sharks so
what happens when these juvenile sharks
become adults and they're swimming
around and they're like hey you remember
that beach with all them tasty humans
let's go back there do they bite they
have teeth don't they
they do have teeth but i like the
parents saying hello sharks it's a new
way of getting acquainted i think i'm
glad somebody's doing it as well you're
getting in the water
okay all right yeah you didn't even let
me finish the question no no no no no
nate it's very common knowledge i'm not
a brave person i